we're all familiar with viral diseases
especially over the past two years the
deadliness and severity of a virus
cannot be understated whether it's covet
19 influenza or any other of the
countless infectious diseases that
plague humanity we're all familiar with
the bubonic plague the black death which
wiped out an estimated 25 million people
in the middle ages a third of europe's
population at the time but that was
during an era in which medieval advances
were limited to the sickening practice
of bloodletting which drained a patient
of their blood until all bacteria left
their system or washing the body with
vinegar of course none of these methods
had any effect on staving off the black
death and the epidemic went down in
history as one of the darkest periods of
civilization but for all our
technological and medical advances in
the field of health and medicine
infectious diseases are still as much of
a threat now as they were back then if
not a greater one think about it in
today's world everything is heavily
connected globalization means that we
travel more import more products than
ever before and with such a high
population density it's difficult to
keep anything under control due to the
sheer amount of people there are in the
world complete eradication of a viral
disease has proven extremely difficult
and even the strictest most regimented
campaigns to do so vaccines while
effective still require time to develop
roll out and treat take for example the
smallpox virus for centuries this deadly
disease slayed entire populations
killing millions with a mortality rate
of 40 percent in the 20th century the
world's governments and medical
organizations worked tirelessly to come
up with a vaccinated cure for the
disease and their efforts eventually
paid off a successful vaccine was
developed and only the trinkling of
cases of smallpox were documented in
somalia in the 1970s today all that
remains of the disease are contained
samples held in high security
laboratories across the world explicitly
used for research purposes but
smallpox's story is not the norm other
diseases you may not realize are still
lurking in the shadows are polio and
malaria polio being a disease affecting
the central nervous system with weakened
muscle function as a result and malaria
being a mosquito transmitted sickness
that results in severe fevers and
vomiting the common perception is that
these illnesses aren't actually a threat
anymore and are nothing more than a
relic of the past but that isn't quite
true while they've been eliminated from
some parts of the world in polio's case
most first world countries such as the
united states and europe
still have some documented cases that
crop up from time to time but the future
is hopeful with only under 50 cases of
polio documented worldwide in the year
2018 and malaria's worldwide eradication
program seeing success year by year
maybe the world will one day be fully
wiped of these terrible illnesses but
why are we telling you this during a
video about the scp foundation because
the subject of today's video is also a
deadly virus but unlike the most
ordinary variations we just discussed
this one is going to be a lot more
difficult to eradicate fully and by
difficult we mean next to impossible as
to be expected with an organization like
the scp foundation the threats they deal
with are both similar to the ones the
rest of the world's governments and
large organizations do and entirely
completely different if you're a cease
and viewer of scp explained chances are
you are already familiar with more than
a few anomalous viruses they are
unspeakably deadly incredibly strange
and can put an infected victim through
more pain and suffering than anything
else in the world it's a testament to
the foundation's thoroughness and
capabilities that some of these diseases
are even able to be concentrated in a
manageable dose and contained inside a
chamber at a secure facility but for
others they're still out there ready to
strike at a moment's notice and there's
absolutely nothing the foundation can do
about it except be as swift as possible
in their retaliation and there's no
doubt that they're prepared with the
deadliness of an anomalous virus which
can spread at a more infectious rate and
potentially alert the rest of the world
to the supernatural happenings of the
scp foundation and the objects they
contain an anomalous pandemic is one of
the foundation's greatest fears some
anomalous diseases as we mentioned
before are under the control of the
foundation take scp-008 nicknamed the
zombie plague for example
scp-008 is a deadly virus that you
guessed it can essentially turn a
patient into a zombie reanimating their
corpse after the sickness kills them
what makes scp-008 unique is that it's
entirely absent from the natural world
save for the places the foundation has
labeled g2 sites these g2 sites are
small pockets across the world in which
the foundation discovered as cp008
which further research of such have
determined that the disease may not have
originated on earth in the first place
subjects infected by scp-008 display
symptoms within three hours of infection
which include flu-like symptoms preceded
by a coma which is followed by death but
after death the victim's body will
continue to display lifeless signs of
mortality including a high durability to
damage and a desire to ingest living
humans on physical contact just like a
zombie research into scp-008 is highly
classified and left out from the
original document because the foundation
has the right to fear that scp-008 may
be replicated in an unsuspecting
laboratory one day as such containment
efforts to prevent such research from
bearing fruit are in place backed by the
foundation's stranglehold over the
ordinary scientific world thankfully as
cp008 has mostly been destroyed with
samples contained solely at the g2 sites
which are now protected foundation
facilities located across the world but
the foundation was lucky that scp-008
was so easily contained if the disease
spread in larger numbers or originated
from a natural source on earth we might
be living in a world more like a zombie
apocalypse movie than the one we know
today on the other side of this spectrum
you have scp-3519
the quiet days virus in one reality
scp-3519 managed to kill off the entire
world due to its severity and ease of
infection unlike most anomalous diseases
scp-3519 was a memetic virus meaning
that its transmission wasn't just
limited to the traditional means of
physical contact but the very idea of it
permeating your mind would allow it to
take root inside your body
scp-3519 permeated the idea that the
world would end on march 5th 2019 and
that self-termination was a preferable
option than living through the
apocalypse and the terrible aftermath
that would follow
scp-3519 took society by storm and the
idea was transmitted through television
broadcasts and news stories encouraging
people to free themselves from the world
and even foundation sites themselves the
foundation was powerless and the rapid
rate of transmission proved too
difficult for the organization to keep
fully under control the project to
create a cure was greenlit but one by
one as foundation sites across the globe
suffered massive die-offs and a loss of
personnel the research team dwindled
down until there was only one person
left a junior researcher by the name of
rory jones who assumed the position of
05-6 in an emergency succession protocol
that would promote the next highest
member of the foundation to the position
in the event of an overseer dying jones
was the only member of the foundation
left and as far as he knew camped up in
a cabin in the woods with nothing but a
few research materials and a computer
terminal the only man alive the
scp-3519 timeline story proves just how
quickly a deadly anomalous virus can get
out of control how it can make an
organization as all-powerful and
ever-prepared as the scp foundation just
another statistic in a record of
infected populations but you don't need
to tell the foundation that they're
already well aware and they've had
decades to prepare study and analyze the
effect an anomalous virus can have on
the world and that brings us to the
mysterious case of the main anomaly
we'll be looking at today
scp-217 the clockwork virus dr charles
gears a researcher of note that you may
have heard of before was one of the
foundation's best and brightest his cold
distant demeanor and propensity for
researching the anomalous commonly
associated with the divergent religion
the church of the broken god a group of
zealots focused on reassembling the
broken metal pieces of their mechanical
technological god made onlookers
associate the gears name with sleek
careless alloys and methodical cold
clockwork when the foundation began
observing symptoms of what would later
be labeled scp-217 in a major population
center whose name would be scrubbed from
all official documents they knew dr
gears was the right man to head the
research efforts for years the
foundation had observed strange medical
records and reports from the city
reports of dementia in subjects younger
than the common age brackets and at
uncommonly high rates high reports of
lethargy depression emotional dulling
and the feeling of something moving
underneath the skin or a ticking noise
in the ear were all signs that the
foundation was dealing with scp-217
dr gears was already familiar with the
disease having worked alongside efforts
to study it in the past this was not the
first major population area affected by
scp-217
and there surely were more areas up next
upon arriving and reading the initial
reports dr gears requested to view a
subject that the foundation believed was
suffering from scp-270
when the young woman entered gears
immediately recognized the signs the
stiff movements the robotic monotone
voice and the way that nothing he seemed
to say faced her they were all clear-cut
signs of
scp-217's infection the girl was barely
high school age but she looked like she
had all of her youth and life zapped out
of her completely it was a horrible
sight to see an x-ray was performed and
gears saw for himself a definitive sign
that scp-217 had taken over her body the
x-ray imagery showed the inside of the
girl's body which had been converted
from an ordinary mass of organs and
tissues into a clockwork machine
composed of cogs gears screws and wires
and as gears knew this would only get
worse as time went on with signs of her
infection appearing outside the body as
well as inside right now there wasn't a
shred of human tissue left inside her
and there was nothing the doctor could
do about it gears thought about the
girl's family who had been anesthetized
prior to the foundation seizing their
daughter for research purposes and
though the emotionless man would never
let his facade down
his heart ached for her but it wasn't
only her it was dozens of people inside
the city the foundation had documented
as displaying symptoms of scp-217
on a scale this high there was little
the foundation could do except sit back
watch and only act when the symptoms
became too visible to hide that was the
tragedy of scp-217 the clockwork virus
it wasn't deadly but it was a slow more
metaphorical death from a person made of
flesh and blood to a clockwork automaton
that felt more like a shell than a
living thing the foundation was more
than familiar with scp-217 though and
multiple samples are held inside a
reverse pressure airlocked containment
chamber at a high security site for
research purposes in hopes that one day
a cure could be developed personnel
wanting to access scp-217 samples have
to don fully insulated hazmat suits with
chemical sterilization and endura
post-interaction quarantine period with
physical testing all this being
mandatory after they have finished their
experiments with the virus the severity
of an scp-217 infection cannot be
understated and any items touched by
infected personnel have to undergo a
strict sterilization process the
foundation is perfectly justified in
this overly cautious behavior too
because
scp-217 has an infection rate of 100
percent meaning that it will transmit
through physical contact all of the time
without failure but it doesn't just
infect humans the clockwork virus has
been observed to infect all
multicellular organisms from the
smallest insect to an elephant
scp-217 consumes and hollows out all it
can clockwork beings wrought from a
clockwork virus marching to the ticking
of their innards in a hollow empty world
if that sounds terrifying and like a
nightmare then congratulations chances
are you're unaffected by scp-217
if it sounds appealing well you might
just be a mechanite ready to serve the
church of the broken god but we'll get
to that connection later
scp-217 is especially difficult to deal
with due to its hardiness it can survive
for years outside a host body and when
it does find a suitable host and trust
us there's no shortage in supply of them
in the world it can sometimes take years
for symptoms of scp-217 to manifest it's
a slow virus and that's exactly what
makes it so dangerous the foundation
might not realize a large population
area has been infected before it's too
late and that's exactly what happened
before with entire towns being infected
by scp-217
but what are those symptoms well you
might have already been able to guess so
far that scp-217 has to do with turning
someone into a mechanical monstrosity
but there's a bit more to it than that
scp-217
alters biochemistry in such a way that
it causes organic matter to rearrange
itself into an organic metal chemical
scans of this metal reveal that there's
still living cellular tissue and dna
present inside it but it takes the
appearance and feels indistinguishable
from actual materials this process
occurs slowly over time and advanced
stages have shown that a subject's
interior will resemble a machine with a
complicated mixture of gears and
clockwork this is subtle barely noticed
by the patient at first with only vague
feelings of confusion insomnia and joint
stiffness but as larger and larger parts
of the body are converted the subject
experiences extreme pain as dr gears
wrote in his research notes on scp-217
hearts are replaced by gears and small
tubes joints by gear networks eyes by
structures not unlike primitive hand
crank film cameras etc
scp-217 and non-mammals shows first on
the outside of the body in mammals such
as humans scp-217 converts the internals
before being visible on the outside of
the body the reason for this is unknown
but it might have something to do with
that broken god connection we mentioned
earlier one of the church's core beliefs
focuses on ascending humanity to reflect
meccan the broken god while the origins
of scp-217 are unknown if the virus is
related to the mechanites this subtle
slow infection may be a part of their
grand design a plan to covertly
infiltrate society and convert the
masses into effigies of their god but of
course this is all speculation as we
mentioned those infected by scp-217 can
be entirely unaware of their conversion
until it's too late but aside from
physicality the mental state is also
affected from the middle to advanced
stages of scp-217 infection victims
behaviors reflect their cold mechanical
insides they respond in a repetitive
disassociated fashion their actions are
dull mechanical and telegraphed they're
easily distracted and confused and
appear irritable when faced with new
problems in the early stages scp-217
manifests as increased lethargy a lack
of emotional response and a feeling of
fluttering or moving underneath the skin
always present are ticking noises like
those of a clock that mainly manifest
when scp-217 infects the shoulders neck
and head but attempts to hear this noise
using recording equipment have
invariably failed as the device will not
pick up any sound if pressed against an
affected area as scp-217s infection
advances the subject will experience
excruciating pain
sharp tearing sensations in the areas
that are being converted into organic
metal compare bowling feeling to a knife
wound or a deep muscle tear this feeling
can persist for hours or days depending
on which area of the body is being
affected and the subject themselves
after tearing the existing organs the
new parts will integrate into the tissue
and settle into the body producing pain
an analysis of this newly formed organic
metal appears to be alloys of brass
steel and iron varieties but substances
such as leather rubber glass and wood
have been observed and observed is the
key word because as soon as these
materials are examined deeper it's
revealed that they're still organic in
composition and even carry the subject's
dna organs and tissues affected will
however become stronger instead of being
squishy meat bags filled with tissue
blood and other parts they take on the
physical properties namely durability of
the material they resemble if one of
these areas are damaged they'll repair
over time just like regular organs but
at a much slower rate but one
interesting note is that a damaged piece
of organic metal can be repaired so to
speak by replacing damaged areas with
new parts of the same type this has had
no consequences and the body will
continue to act as normal that's one
benefit of being infected by scp-217
you can essentially repair yourself with
whatever you have access to but the
conversion of a victim doesn't stop it
continues to occur until their entire
body is organic metal inside and out dr
gears research on a fully converted
brain was apparently so groundbreaking
that it had to be erased from the
standard security class documentation we
can only speculate on what it contained
possibly that connection to the broken
god that we're so desperate to make we
don't know but whatever it was it hinted
at something far larger than what a
cursory look at scp-217
seems to suggest
scp-217 is truly one of the most
dangerous anomalous viruses the
foundation has to deal with having
already infected hundreds of people in
various population centers around the
world before containment methods can be
properly established so if you happen to
start hearing the sounds of a tick here
and a talk there accompanied by a
strange fluttering feeling under your
skin we're sorry to say there's not much
we can do for you now actually
nothing there's nothing we can do now go
check out scp-914 the clockworks and
scp-001 the broken god or boro cycle for
more mechanite related videos from scp
explained